Speaker 1: OK. This you have to see Donald Trump
is really in trouble with his own followers.
Donald Trump has made two pro-vaccine public
comments over the last week or 10 days,
and he is in so much trouble with his own
followers that he had to go to Marjorie Taylor
Greene to try to clean it up. Let me remind you
of what took place. First of all, at the Trump
Bill O'Reilly event, from last, I believe it
was early last week or late the previous week,
Donald Trump saying the is good and I got the
booster and the crowd booing. Take a look.
Speaker 5: But look, we did something that
was historic. We saved tens of millions of
lives worldwide. We together, all of us. Not
me. We we got a vaccine done. Three vaccines
done and tremendous therapeutics like Regeneron
and other things that have saved a lot of lives.
We got a vaccine done in less than nine
months that was supposed to take from
five to 12 years because of that vaccine, because
of that vaccine. Millions and millions of people,
I think this would have been the Spanish
flu of 1917, where up to one hundred million
people died. This was going to ravage the
country far beyond what it is right now.
Take credit for it. Take credit for it's
a great what we've done is historic.
Don't let them take it away. Don't take it
away from ourselves. You're playing that.
You're playing right into their hands when you
sort of like all the vaccine. If you don't want
to take it, you shouldn't be forced to take it.
No mandates. But take credit because we saved
tens of millions of lives. Take credit. Don't let
them take that away from you. OK, so the president
made. Do you agree with that right?
Speaker 4:
Both the president and I are
vaccinated. You get the booster.
Yes, I got it too.
Speaker 5: OK, so on da da da da da DA Nang, and
that's always a very tiny group of.
Speaker 1: So that was the first
incident. Second incident was Donald Trump
interviewed by Candace Owens, Candace Owens
wanting to do the anti-vax stuff with Trump
and Trump saying, no, the vaccines are good,
the vaccines are an accomplishment, and the people
that are getting sick and dying are the people
who are unvaccinated. Remember that clip?
Speaker 3: We see the corruption, right?
It doesn't seem like anybody ever pays for the
corruption. And right now, we're seeing corruption
life, even in terms of big pharma, which is a
huge topic on the minds of mothers, especially,
you're seeing what's happening at these school
board meetings. Where do you stand on these
vaccine mandates? And obviously, I know that you
are your pro vaccine obviously did everything you
could to get this vaccine out. I know it was
Speaker 5: one of the greatest
achievements we did the last
Speaker 3: nine months and to be able to do that.
But now we've taken a twist, right? It's it's
gotten now we went from this is a good thing and
people should have this option to military men.
You're going to have to resign because you're not
getting this vaccine. Where do you stand on that?
Speaker 5: Well, I stand on forget about the
mandates that people have to have
their freedom. But at the same time,
the vaccine is one of the greatest achievements
of mankind. We would have had in 1917. Remember
the Spanish flu killed perhaps a hundred million
people? Actually, it ended the First World War
because the soldiers was a lot of people
don't know that the soldiers got so sick.
It was a terrible thing. There were no vaccines.
It would know anything. I came up with a vaccine
with three vaccines. All are very, very good. Came
up with three of them in less than nine months.
It was supposed to take five to 12 years
Speaker 3: and we should people have died
under COVID this year. By the way, under Joe
Biden, then under you and more people took the
vaccine this year. So people are questioning how
Speaker 5: the vaccine worked. But some people
aren't the ones. The ones who get very sick and
go to the hospital are the ones that don't take
the vaccine. But it's still their choice. And
if you take the vaccine, you're protected. Look,
the results of the vaccine are very good, and
if you do get it, it's a very minor form. People
aren't dying when they take the vaccine, but
Speaker 3: the masking of children, this
Speaker 1: has thrown the Trump world into a
tailspin. We talked about it yesterday. So many
Trump followers believe that they have been
backstab for lack of a better term by Donald
Trump. And so Donald Trump now trying to clean
it up through Marjorie Taylor Greene and Marjorie
Taylor Greene is sort of the perfect person to do
it. As an anti-vax Republican, she put together
this big Twitter thread where she says, I just got
off the phone with Trump. We talked about vaccines
and mandates. We talked about COVID and how the
virus from China has been politicized. She says,
I have President Trump's permission to tell you
all. He is 100 percent against the mandates,
but he encourages everyone to get the vaccine.
He also said if he was president, he would never
mandate vaccines and no one would be fired. The
key thing to remember is where COVID came from
China. We should be holding those who made
the virus accountable, made the virus,
made the virus a very dubious term, given what we
know about it and protecting our freedoms while
promoting life saving treatments and giving the
vaccines to those who want it. Not forced, not
forced for everyone that criticizes Trump about
when COVID started, which should occur to voters.
I think his administration did the best they
could. The virus was brand new. We've never seen
anything like it. Biden deserves the criticism,
and then they just move on to other apologies.
Trump says you wouldn't be paying these gas prices
if he was in charge. Keystone would be under four
under construction. Biden is a disgrace on an
on going on to talk about Iran and other things.
This is actual sort of crisis management done in
a really, really strange way, Trump said something
for once. That's true. And for once, that's
uncontroversial. The people disproportionately
dying from COVID are the people without a
vaccine, even in the context of Omicron,
as we talked about earlier. And Trump's audience
is so weaponized against him that they went nuts,
and now he's going to Marjorie Taylor Greene
to try to help him clean it up. Let's hope
that this is Trump's undoing. Trump
finally telling the truth about something.
Maybe his undoing with his own
followers. The monster he created
is completely out of control and has turned
against him, and it is delightful to see